so faker one Worlds the other week he
beat the final boss of League of Legends
after Chasing his fourth title for seven
years he said he has no plans to retire
anytime soon and T1 have said they're
keeping the dream team together for 2024
so the question is can Faker do it all
again next
[Music]
year thanks to Rog for sponsoring this
video here's the to tell you more about
their Black Friday sale that ends today
all right first things first if you are
in the market for a killer gaming
monitor boy do I have some good news for
you Gamers this year Rog are having an
exclusive 15% off Black Friday sale on
their Swift OLED pg27 aqm monitor only
on Amazon we actually just partnered
with Rog for a cracked where Colton and
I built a god tier rig just to test out
rog's new 540 HZ monitor that said all
of rog's gaming displays are top tier
and the pg27 is no exception it's the
brightest OLED gaming monitor on the
market boasting colors and contrast that
you need to see to believe the pg27 also
offers 1440p resolution and a 240 Herz
refresh rate which is pretty much the
perfect combination for any real capital
G gamer so head over to Amazon if you're
in need of a stellar upgrade that won't
break the bank now back to the video all
right so we had this the other week and
again see Faker especially looking on
while his teammates are raising the cup
as well he's done it three times this is
the first time and he'll hoist it for
the
fourth and this week every player in the
world would have seen this in game if
they were paying close enough attention
look at the trophy in Top
Lane holy that's in the
game wait that's crazy I didn't notice
that faker's fourth world title 10 years
after his first 7 years after his last
the goat is back on top etc etc etc
there was so much buildup to the finals
we kept wondering whether or not Faker
could win and not what would happen
after he succeeded one concern a few
months ago was that Faker might retire
if he won worlds and that does make
sense he's done it all he's had his
Redemption Arc now this year marks 10
years since his professional debut it
would have looked nice and neat in the
history books but Faker said at the
post-finals media conference that he'll
continue to work with T1 while still
contracted with them and would think
about retirement at a later date another
concern was that T1 wouldn't keep the
roster together in September t18 car
Gushi told a South Korean news outlet
that he thought 2023 would be the last
world they'd play together as a team
then during worlds itself zo said in a
T1 interview that although their shared
struggles had brought them together
something felt off this time and it
might be the last tournament they
participated in of course that was
before they went and won the whole thing
I think becoming world champions can
kind of help make you forget the bad
times on Wednesday last week T1 teased
that the roster would be staying
together before officially announcing
that the Players whose contracts were up
Gushi ker and zos had all resigned with
T1 for another year this team's
longevity is something else this current
roster has existed since owner joined
the others in December 20120 starting in
Spring next year they have been playing
together for 3 years that's not just
rare for elite team that is rare for any
roster can this familiarity and
stability help the team run it back in
2024 well if there's any truth to the
phrase if it ain't broke don't fix it
then you really don't need to fix T1
right now they're fresh world champions
they're all best-in roll contenders I
didn't even think their bot lanane are
contenders at this point I think they
genuinely are just the best bot Lane in
the world probably have been for about a
year or so this team have shown they can
adapt to shifting Mets and even the
younger members now have battle hardened
experience the only maj major change is
the return of T1 Legend coma as their
head coach he oversaw the SKT Dynasty in
faker's early days as the team went on
to win three worlds in four years a
couple of msis and a string of domestic
titles that's a world championship
coaching stuff in
2016 it's coma with a TV on a chair with
a notepad since coma left in 2019 T1
have had seven different coaches and the
thinking was that Faker had become the
de facto strategic coach so it will be
interesting to see how the two work
together now but other teams looking to
take t1s Crown in 2024 have made much
more sweeping changes perhaps the
greatest example of this is Jen G who
have been somewhat of a cryptonite for
T1 over the past couple of years the day
after the world's final they announced
the release of four of their starting
roster including chovi after a nervous
week for fans they announced the return
of chovi and lens alongside keen paay
and Canyon that is a terrifying roster
if you wanted to construct a team in a
lab that could take down T1 at this
point it would probably look something
like this LS believes it's the single
best team chovy has ever had surrounding
him and that the only foreseeable hurdle
for a team like this is their Synergy so
the team that has beaten T1 in three out
of the last four lck titles seems to
have got an upgrade don't expect next
year to be a walking apart for T1 and
that's not even mentioning other
confirmed rosters like Han life's
eight-man super team r
next year is going to be spicy we don't
have too much confirmed about LPL teams
yet but you know they're going to be
back with vengeance next year T1 had a
pretty Rocky 2023 All Things Considered
that ended in spectacular fashion jdg
had a pretty impeccable 2023 that ended
with them stumbling at one of the final
hurdles they were so close to achieving
the Golden Road winning everything a
team possibly could in a single year but
for T1 let's say they hold their nerve
let's say their Synergy Remains the
metas suit them coma jails with a team
and they're able to stay one step ahead
of the competition is it realistic to
expect them to win Worlds next year it's
important to look back at historical
precedence here to remind ourselves of
one thing it is very hard to defend a
World's title in fact it's only ever
happened once in 2016 when SKT defended
it in a thrilling five game series
versus Samsung Galaxy other than that no
team has ever done it back to back you
can even go one step further with this
there have only ever been four teams
that have even made it to back-to-back
finals starh horn Royal Club in 2014
Samsung Galaxy in 2017 Daman gaming in
2021 and T1 in 2023 but it's simply it's
not an easy task their fan base is
already notoriously harsh on them last
year Faker sued toxic fans who harassed
him over T's performances in recent
years as much as I'd like them to be
satisfied with this recent world's title
it may have simply raised the bar of
expectation for them so is it
unrealistic to not only expect T1 to
make it back to finals next year but
actually win the whole thing well one
thing to remember is that the form T1
showed at World this year wasn't just a
fluke it wasn't a flash in the pan they
have been one of the strongest teams in
the world for about 2 years now they
just haven't had much to show for it
until now in Spring 2022 they broke a
record by being the first team in lck
history to achieve a perfect 18-0 split
the previous record of 14-0 had stood
for 7even years and was set by other
than SKT and Faker so we know they can
maintain a high level of play over a
long period of time and there's no
reason to expect this wouldn't continue
into next year especially with this
recent conference boost just because
winning back-to-back finals has only
ever happened once before doesn't mean
this iteration of T1 can't do that again
maybe even go on and achieve the Golden
Road next year think about it next year
T1 wins spring they win MSI they win
summer they win World they achieve the
goal Golden Road something that's never
been done before and then Faker retires
how poetic would that be it's not
unimaginable Faker and this iteration of
T1 constantly break records smash
expectations and do the unthinkable look
a lot can change in a year in 2016 it
looked like nobody in the world could
stop Faker and SKT and a year later the
SKT dynasty was over now I know that was
a different era different teammates but
my point is it's hard to predict the
future we didn't know where we'll be in
6 months never mind 12 but the
foreseeable future does look bright they
have the talent they have their Synergy
they have their legendary coach back and
they have the greatest player to ever
live making back-to-back world's finals
is not easy only four teams have ever
done that winning back-to-back world is
even harder only five players have ever
achieved it and of them only one is
still playing his name is Faker and in
2024 he might just do it
again uh um I think fak is going to do
uh what football players do you know
when they retire from Europe and they go
and play in you know North America or
Saudi League or whatever or Australia or
something I think fake is going to go
play for like a small Esports Club in
like
Stoke uh in England you know maybe Wales
maybe he'll do maybe he'll play for
Cardiff or something but I can see that
it's that's where the money is you know
that's where the money is when he
retires he'll play for Rex FC why not I